de retour du froid de l'hiver ravive la
lutte au virus
une véritable manne pour l'industrie
pharmaceutique quoique les remèdes
maison ou remettre de grand-mère jour
plan combattre le re munich et des
recettes de grand mère
si vous avez de la toux les oignons ali
mellah d'eau chaude à la sécurité
restait leur vivent dans un
environnement où il n'y a pas quelqu'un
de contaminer je roule je trouve le
robot du bal avec de l'eau ça enlève la
tour c'est vexant tu les pieds avec des
groupes d'élèves ensevelis
[Musique]
je n'ai pas encore trouvé leur nature et
restez chez vous qui donnez à nador
boissons chaudes avec 10 30 g gens de
miel du j'aime bien c'est pas mon truc
moi je suis monsieur citron e semaine
catherine pons qui quinze jours qu'un
soin couper le citron comme des déployer
complètement réchauffer ça et puis
prendre ça tue toutes sortes de maladies
ça c'est quelque chose que ma grand mère
m'a enseigné donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait
remèdes maison ou produits en pharmacie
ou encore un mélange des deux quoi
penser quoi faire que nous dit la
science on viens de l'entendre bouchra
chacun sa petite approche ans pour faire
face à la grippe mais cinq cas toujours
une petite confusion qui s'installe
risquer des repères des trucs qu'on peut
donner
mais la principale confusion souvent
c'est que les gens confondent le rhume
et la grippe pour la grippe porcine qui
ont un vaccin
il faut justement les gens hésitent à se
faire vacciner parce qu'ils se disent
c'est pas si grave que ce sujet la
grille parce qu'ils pensent aux rhumes
le rhume c'est pas très grave on peut la
voir quelques fois par année ont le nez
qui coule mais la grippe par contre si
beaucoup plus grave ces erreurs en fait
qu'on a la grippe dans une vie mais
quand on l'a on l'a beaucoup de fièvre
on est cloué au lit on ne m'attend
toupie même pour des gens plus
vulnérables des personnages et des bébés
ça peut carrément tuer la grippe
donc si pour ce que des campagnes pour
inciter les gens à se faire vacciner
dudit vaccin 10 mythes entourant les
vaccins il y en a quelques uns des plus
courant c'est que les gens ont peur des
effets secondaires du vaccin donc tous
les vaccins ont des effets secondaires
mais parfois les gens ont peur
d'attraper la grippe avec le vaccin
en fait le vaccin contre la grippe c'est
un vaccin qui inactive et le virus est
mort donc aucune chance que ça ne donne
la grippe par contre il peut arriver
c'est que ça prend deux semaines avant
que le vaccin fasse effet et durant ces
deux semaines là on peut quand même
attrapé la grippe de quelqu'un autour de
nous et y penser à tort que c'est le
vaccin que donné le virus pendant du
vaccin évidemment il ya toutes sortes de
produits qui existent en pharmacie des
produits naturels des 15 groupes comme
on les appelle
est ce qu'on doit penser au sujet de
tous ces médicaments là donc
premièrement une fois qu'on a les
premiers symptômes du rhume ou la grippe
on ne peut pas arrêter
le virus donc pas de casse croûte ça
n'existe pas et il ya beaucoup de
produits naturels justement qui
prétendent à tort vous aider à guérir
plus rapidement même chose pour la
vitamine c
ça ne sert à rien de prendre la vitamine
c pour guérir plus vite
même chose pour les onguents les
produits qu'on se met sur la peau ça
peut aider un peu à respirer mieux le
lait les produits à vendre le mans
d'eucalyptus
mais encore une fois ça n'agit pas à
l'intérieur du corps quand on parle de
produits naturels aussi des fois des
gens disent bon c'est pas grave c'est
naturel c'est sans manger
mais en fait même les ingrédients
naturels peuvent interagir avec d'autres
médicaments
donc il faut faire attention quand on
prend ces produits leur surtout quand on
le d'autres médicaments prescrits pour
d'autres maladies
voilà qui éclaire parlons des lattes ou
les sirops contre la toux ou encore là
l'efficacité
oui ou non les sirops contre la toux
soit aussi l'efficacité elle n'est pas
vraiment clair
en fait ce qui pourrait fonctionner tout
aussi bien que ses roues complètes tout
se prendre une cuillérée à soupe de miel
par contre ce qui fonctionne dans le
rayon plus des médicaments en vente
libre
tout ce qui est un analgésique donc pour
aider à réduire la fièvre des douleurs
sosa n
mais encore une fois ça agissent sur les
symptômes donc ça n'aide pas à guérir
plus vite ça aide à avoir un peu moins
mal le temps que ça va durer donc
finalement est vraiment la seule chose à
faire c'est prendre du repos et
d'attendre que ça passe du mossad le
miel ça fait penser aux autres remèdes
de grand-mère les recettes maison
finalement qu'on a tous développé au fil
des ans ce qu'est ce que l'on peut
cependant penser mais tant que c'est par
exemple de prendre des soupes de prendre
des tisanes quand on est malade on a
besoin de s'hydrater les fonds transpire
beaucoup on se déshydrate
donc ça peut aider à se réhydrater donc
peu importe les ingrédients les remèdes
de grand-mère sa hausse cet avantage là
la sicile et nous y serons c'est bon
mais elle n'importe quel support et le
même effet puis surtout ça apporte du
réconfort et sont dans le besoin quand
on est malade c'est sûr mais au delà de
la quête de réconfort que ce soit pour
prévenir ou guérir des problèmes de
santé
qu'est ce qui fait qu'on se tourne
parfois vers internet plutôt que vers un
médecin ou un pharmacien
vient cette confiance envers des sources
d'information pour la fiabilité souvent
remise en question pourquoi la santé
peut parfois être un vecteur si puissant
la désinformation
alors en fait déjà parce que il est
question de notre vie des conditions
dans lesquelles on va vivre notre vie on
cherche beaucoup d'informations sur ça
ça fait partie par exemple un des
premiers résultats dans les moteurs de
recherche de choses comme ça
le deuxième critère c'est un phénomène
qui est plus de un autre au fait qu'on
vit notre corps donc on vit notre santé
on a une expérience sensorielle de deux
notes santé on se sent en pleine forme
où on a l'impression que tel produit
nous fait du bien qui on nous dit qu'en
fait non c'est pas vrai ça c'est
toujours un peu problématique de
remettre en cause ce vécu sensorielle et
dans ce cas là bas ça laisse la brèche
justement pour payer d'autres
explications qui vont aller plus dans le
sens de ce que nous on ressent il ya un
dernier critère qui lui est plus social
et qui va être notre rapport au système
de santé est ce qu on lui fait confiance
au palais ce qu'on est déjà défiance
vis-à-vis du système de santé
et puis est-ce qu'on n'y a accès ou pas
si on n'a pas facilement accéder on va
aller chercher de l'information ailleurs
sur internet notamment
c'est ce qui pousse déjà devrais je en
plus sur le web c'est un trou exactement
alors c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose
qui est assez frappant quand on constate
la différence entre la manière qu'on a
de valoriser un le discours de d'experts
reconnus en santé et puis des gourous en
santé quand on par exemple on discrédite
le discours d'un gourou en santé et
personnes vont répondre sur mais elle
est disponible mais elle est empathique
mais elle elle nous répond et puis elle
est plus proche de nous et puis elle
fait attention elle répond à nos
questions et dans cette histoire notre
senti recherche ça montre que en fait on
n'est pas juste des êtres de pure
rationalité qui nous transmettons des
informations il ya aussi une relation
quand on fait ça si le message et
entretient pas en même temps une
relation de qualité avec la personne des
fois ça peut aller jusqu'à faire en
sorte qu'on refuse le l'information et
on est tout à fait capable d'être de
mauvaise foi et irrationnel vaine course
et ce serait justifié d'y croire on n'a
pas envie d'y croire et puis on a tous
des croyances qui s'associent un lot de
drames exactement des remèdes de
grand-mère beaucoup de savoir
expérientiel en dix ans mais nous on a
toujours fait comme ça et puis ça a
marché donc le tout ça c'est convoqué
ces échanges et en se donnant des
conseils souvent avec une bonne foi on
se rabat tiens c'était ma
add je te conseille de faire ça ça ira
mieux etc et c'est pas nécessairement la
désinformation les remèdes de grand mère
mais non pas du tout c'est justement je
ne faudrait surtout pas se dire qu'il ya
discours scientifique est vrai et puis
le reste c'est de là c'est de la magie
etc
c'est là dedans il ya déjà des choses
qui s'avère complètement erronée et puis
des fois il ya des choses qui vont être
simplement pas vérifié pour pas
vérifiables mais comment dans ce
contexte les experts la santé peuvent
s'insérer pour aider les gens on
remarque qu'ils ont
pas énormément d'intérêt à être présent
en ligne et puis qu'en général quand ils
sont présents lycée plutôt pour diffuser
leurs avis leurs connaissances et c'est
alors que les personnes cherche pas à
avoir une information générale sur la
santé elles veulent un truc ponctuelles
précis particulier sur ce qui est en
train de leur arrivée et donc la manière
d'être présente pourrait être inversé
quelqu'un qui arrive et avant que vous
ayez eu le temps de lui poser une
question vous dit ce qu'il en pense
ça marche moins bien que quand on écoute
d'abord la question pour que la personne
soit reconnue comme une autorité
compétente fiable et cetera c'est quand
même plus efficace
[Musique]